[Ukraїner
Експедиція]
У Миньковецькій державі було чотири резиденції.
[Поділля,
селище Отроків]
Це весняна резиденція графа Мархоцького,
він же граф Редукс.
В Україні замків і палаців дуже багато.
Колись Україну називали «Гардарікою» — країною замків.
[Ігор Скальський
підприємець, меценат]
Історія замків і палаців проста: тут жили якісь пани.
Одне покоління, друге, третє.
Вони жили для себе.
У цього замку історія зовсім інша.
Молодий Мархоцький, який начитався Вольтера і Жан-Жака Руссо,
отримав спадок від свого дядька 15 сіл.
Він почав створювати Миньковецьку державу.
В 1792 році вони встановили тут межові знаки
між панством Миньковецим і царством Російським.
У Миньковецькій державі діяв суд присяжних,
якого у нас до сих пір немає.
Вони намагалися будувати справедливе суспільство.
Мархоцький казав, що дає людям закони,
не ті, що їм потрібні, а яких вони зможуть дотримуватися.
Він довів, що злагода і порядок у суспільстві
можуть існувати без революції.
Адже у той час Франція заливалася кров'ю.
А тут діяла Миньковецька держава.
Тож коли Мархоцького ув'язнили,
селяни клопотали про його звільнення.
У 2008 році до мене зателефонували друзі,
сказали, що свідки Єгови з Чернівців хочуть купити це приміщення, будуть торги.
Я взяв участь в торгах і переміг.
Це коштувало 40 тис. гривень —
пару відсотків від того,
що довелося пізніше сюди вкласти.
Мархоцький любив будувати.
Колись був п'ятибаштовий замок,
але в 30-ті роки його перетворили в свинарники.
Тут все було обкладено плиткою, стирчали гаки.
Різали худобу, був ковбасний цех.
Донедавна у нас на площі бігали свині,
ми їх прогнали
і проводимо там фестиваль Отроків
і фестиваль лазерного шоу.
Надалі будуть відбуватися молодіжні заходи.
Там у нас приміщення музею.
Перед тим, як зробити виставу
я об'їздив майже всю Західну Україну.
Відвідував замки і палаци.
Я член товариства УТОПІК —
Українське товариство охорони пам'яток історії та культури.
Я люблю пам'ятки, я закоханий в нашу історію.
Письмові пам’ятки можна перекрутити,
а архітектурні пам’ятки — їх не вкрадеш,
їх можна знищувати, і їх багато знищували.
Але їх набагато складніше оббрехати.
В Хмельницькій області є біля 2 тис. пам'яток архітектури місцевог о значення
Вони до сих пір не паспортизовані, не взяті на облік.
Можливість їхнього збереження відсутня.
Рано чи пізно люди починають розуміти,
що спадщиною треба займатися.
Займатися серйозно.
Це фундамент, на якому ми стоїмо.
Коли у тебе його вибивають з-під ніг,
ти падаєш на коліна.
Я б хотів відродити Миньковецьку державу.
Мархоцький звільнив людей від рабства,
від панщини.
Проте ми надалі знаходимося в рабстві.
В полоні своїх генетичних програм і стереотипів.
Автомати виконують програми, які створювали не ми.
Реінкарнація — це реальна річ.
В мені живе частина Мархоцького.
Він не вмер.
Справа, що робиться для інших продовжує жити.
Те, що ми робимо лише для себе —
іде з нами до могили.
Чому саме в цьому місці?
Тому що тут існувала традиція:
жити не для себе, а задля майбутнього.
Ми просто продовжуємо цю традицію.
[Автор проєкту
Богдан Логвиненко]
[Оператори
Павло Пашко, Олександр Портян]
[Продюсерка
Оля Шор]
[Сценаристка
Каріна Пілюгіна]
[Режисер
Микола Носок]
[Монтажерка
Анна Воробйова]
[Субтитрувальник
Владислав Цовма]
[Ukraїner
Експедиція]